julia roberts is gracing the cover of
Harper's Bazaar rockin pink tulle and
sneaks while inside the pages she's
talking to Oprah all about fear Fame and
Taylor Swift so what did Julia's three
kids think about their mom status as
Hollywood royalty they have no idea
she's America's Sweetheart in fact their
big question was are you more famous
than Taylor Swift but we know her
favorite role in life is being mom
what's the best thing about being a mama
I love all of it it is it's my honor and
my privilege but who knew she was afraid
of heights
Julia conquers her fear rock climbing
and Couture for the November issue of
Harper's Bazaar opening up to Oprah
about life in the spotlight and how
tough it can be on her 16-year marriage
to husband Danny Motor she says
sometimes we are in the grocery store
and we'll see a tabloid and we'll all be
standing there like oh that's
uncomfortable it can still hurt my
feelings because I'm so proud of my
marriage just exit luckier Roberts also
admits social media can get her down she
just got on the ground because her kids
asked her to but this pic with her niece
got some online hate the number of
people who felt absolutely required to
talk about how terrible I looked at the
picture that I'm not aging well that I
look like a man I was amazed at how that
made me feel I'm a 50 year old woman and
I Know Who I am and still my feelings
got hurt
still Julia's happy place is with her
kids and while she tells Oprah shall
probably never watch pretty woman with
them Steel Magnolias is a definite yes I
just like the idea growing old with
somebody
[Music]
[Applause]